et la totalité des banques qui ont prêté
de l'argent à leur business sont réunis
depuis cet après midi afin de se
prononcer sur ce plan de sauvetage
alors comment en est on arrivé là le
parc accusent nous le savons 21
milliards de dettes mais la
fréquentation n'est pas en cause les
explications frédérique hovasse et de
denis pagé à euro disney on s'accroche à
son siège de nouveau déficit pour
l'année 92 93 5 milliards 3 school et
financier en cause les erreurs de
gestion et de prévisions dénoncé par un
récent audit heureux disney a voulu
calquer le modèle de gestion pratique et
à disney world et a mis trop de temps à
rectifier le tir
rectifié le tir ce fut d'abord une
nouvelle politique de prix entrée en
fonction de la saison création de
forfaits avec par exemple l'accès libre
ou le transport gratuit pour les enfants
lors de voyages organisés les
restaurants sont moins chers plus adapté
et dans tout le parc des petits camions
vendre de la nourriture à emporter les
boutiques proposent maintenant davantage
de produits disney pour les hôtels au
cimic et a dû revoir sa copie car le
taux d'occupation global en 93 et de 55%
quasiment mp nationalement mais très
inférieur à celui de paris 72 %
par contre les hôtels économiques marche
bien occupé à 70 % c'est beaucoup mieux
que la moyenne d'île de france hors
paris
mais pour la walt disney company les
hôtels ne creuse en rien leurs déficits
il invoque la conjoncture économique les
taux d'intérêt élevés avec aujourd'hui
une inflation presque nulle douleur à
milliard 7,2 frais financiers par an
pour eux il y à aussi la crise de
l'immobilier qui les a forcés à rester
propriétaire de leur hôtel alors qu'il
souhaitait les vendre ce qui aurait
permis d'éponger une partie de leur
dette
et puis les clients consomment moins que
prévu les visiteurs sont pourtant
rendez-vous d'aladdin ou d' indiana
jones et les queues sont souvent
interminables mais les histoires de
picsou n'empêche pas les nouveaux
projets ni donald de préparer sa
nouvelle parade pour dans dix jours
car l'objectif de roe disney est
d'atteindre un résultat net positif en
non mais